what is something unique that ralph does
for you
as a scene partner that you wish you saw
on more sets out there i think ralph
is a plethora of personal anecdotes
that are always entertaining and always
knowledgeable and it makes you feel like
you know a little bit more about ralph
so i do wish that more people would tell
me more fun anecdotes
like ralph macchio does that is very
fair
all right a specific now that i love
from the trailer and wound up loving in
the season and thankfully it's in the
trailer cause we could talk about it in
non-spoiler territory
what was your reaction when you first
read the scene with chris and amanda
uh well i knew uh every season um
before we get started the creators sit
us down and kind of give us the general
vibe of what our characters will be
doing during the season and give us kind
of an idea what to expect and they were
like
and you're gonna slap crease and i was
like i gotta start they're like
it's almost done it's uh but i was
very excited then on the day i was so
nervous because
i've never worked with martin he is you
know
he's like this other part of the show
that i never get to interact with so i
was like oh god it's martin cove even
though like
we see each other in the makeup trailer
we see each other and talk to each other
like hey um and then they had a stunt
coordinator
there for me because that was my big
stunt and they were you know and
martin's done a bajillion
stunts in his day so he he was guiding
me and they were all showing me how to
do it so it looks like i'm hitting and
blah blah blah we'd do it a couple times
and they're like all right one more time
courtney and i'm like feeling really
good about myself
hauled off and just cracked him right
across the face like and they say when
you do stunts to never
stop like i say when they do stunts you
know me i do stunts
you say never stop if you actually make
contact with somebody
just keep going because not only will
you just hit somebody but then you just
ruin the shot so
so i think that is the take they use in
the
in the episode with me actually making
contact with his face but they cut away
from my face because i'm pretty sure it
looks something like this
i meant to do that i'm glad you followed
the rules because it looks great
i think so i'm very i'm very excited
about it did
that slap give you the itch to get into
more stunt work maybe next season
i pitch it every year i know that that
would be
amanda the show would have to jump the
shark i think that is season like
17 territory right there when they're
like and amanda does karate but
i would love to have just like one
one just badass and then just move on i
feel
or something before season 17 yes
something
so you got your first big scene with
martin what were your expectations going
into working with him and then what did
he do to surprise you
uh my expectations were that it was
i don't know if i had expectations i was
just nervous because also he's been part
of this universe for a long time and of
course i work with ralph all the time
but i'm used to it now
but i've never worked with martin and
and his
skill set um so i think going in my
my expectations were just don't mess
this up courtney um
and he's so lovely and he's so fun even
when you slap him
he is very warm and fuzzy about it
maybe he liked it i'm not just kidding
he was definitely
he definitely made me feel very
comfortable he's one of the more
clapping scenes
none of that surprises me about him so i
don't know if there's a simple answer to
this question but i do have to ask you
about it because
you're so good at it this season in
particular and it's
nailing the timing and the intonation on
your dialogue so i don't know is there
any kind of feeling that comes over you
when you deliver a line
just the right way where you know you
got it
well i thank you um i think the writers
definitely give me a particular
very specific lines i feel like they
write for my
voice a little bit um i think they
really make them complicated sometimes
they always add like that extra word in
even ralph will be like oh they're
giving you a courtney line right now
like here's another here's another
singer for you
um uh so usually i just hope i get all
the words out
so there's really nothing comes over me
other than like
let's do this oh it worked did it work
it works
it works quite a few times this season
do you have a favorite amanda one-liner
that comes to mind
uh i love the tanko and cash line oh you
guys
aren't actually cops you know that right
i think that's maybe my favorite
love the new season you are fantastic in
it thank you so much for your time today
thank you so much